this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description get 20% off the annual
subscription on November 8th 2016 at
8:15 p.m. TVs across India flickered in
unison dramas cricket matches and game
shows were all replaced with the face of
Prime Minister Modi in this unscheduled
surprise address he announced the 500
and 1000 rupee banknotes worth about 7
and 14 u.s. dollars respectively would
soon lose their status as legal tender
without any monetary value they would
become nothing but pieces of paper
useless for any and all transactions
soon meant in 3 hours and 45 minutes
effective immediately
at midnight and those 500 and 1000 rupee
bills constituted no less than 86% of
all cash in circulation it was as if the
US president suddenly announced all 10
and 20 dollar bills or worthless only
with a population four times bigger and
far more reliant on cash the next few
months were the result of a fascinating
unintended experiment as 1.3 billion
people scrambled to replace their cash
the government rushed to print new bills
and dozens of people died in the process
India runs on cash it's estimated that
measured by volume 92 98 percent of all
transactions in the country involve
physical currency and 85 percent of
workers are paid in cash while only
about half the population owns a bank
account these are optimal conditions for
tax theft making it extremely easy and
extremely common for earnings to go
unreported and thus unknown and
untracked by the government the informal
underground economy makes up something
like 25 to 40 percent of the nation's
GDP while salaried workers have taxes
automatically withheld from their
paychecks they represent only a tenth of
all organized workers farmers meanwhile
who make up about half the populations
workforce are largely exempt protected
from politicians by their large voting
power
not unlike seniors in the United States
in 2016 only 37 million Indians filed
tax returns 10 million of which were
exempt leaving only a tiny 27 million
payers in a country of 1.3 billion
Modi's solution was simple force
everyone to report their earnings from
November 9th Indians had until December
30th to take their 500 and 1000 rupee
notes to the bank there they could be
deposited for their full value or
exchanged for other notes at the counter
for maximum of 4 thousand rupees per
person per day later increased to four
thousand five hundred and then reduced
to two thousand tax avoiders big and
small now had no choice but to declare
their wealth or lose it all come January
any strange large deposits without
explanatory paperwork would be an
instant red flag for the government but
here's where everything went wrong the
central bank couldn't prepare millions
of new replacement bank notes in secrets
printing them in advance would therefore
attract attention potentially caused
chaos and alert the very criminals the
policy was meant to target for this
reason the Reserve Bank could only start
printing the new five hundred and two
thousand rupee notes after the
announcement leaving it with just under
four
hours to reprint the vast majority of
the second most populous nations
currency clearly it was an impossible
task now having to bring cash to deposit
or exchange would have been disruptive
enough for many Indians but because the
new banknotes were in such short supply
long lines formed outside banks and ATMs
for months on top of that the
replacement bills were slightly smaller
requiring ATMs to be retrofitted to use
them there were lawsuits strikes and
protests against what many saw as an
unreasonable interference by the
government in daily life and despite all
that there's good reason to be skeptical
the policy achieved its intended effects
broadly speaking there were two goals of
de monetization first to weaken
terrorist funding and second to target
the informal black economy both of which
are hard to measure whether terrorist
groups suffered any significant losses
as a result of D monetization
no one knows with certainty and the
black market is problematic precisely
because it can't be measured
what we do know according to the Reserve
Bank of India itself is that ninety nine
point three percent of the demonetised
notes were later returned in other words
the policy removed only a tiny amount of
money from circulation experts largely
agree black money is mostly stored in
the form of gold silver real estate and
overseas bank accounts not bills worth
seven or fourteen US dollars each it's
true that D monetization added a record
nine million new taxpayers but the mass
disruption it caused also removed nearly
the same amount eight point eight
million people stopped paying that year
likely as a result of lost income and
while digital payments experienced a
significant spike in usage there was no
lasting effect after the new banknotes
were fully distributed three years later
the only certain outcome of D
monetization was the immediate chaos it
created across the nation hours wasted
at the bank financial uncertainty for
those most vulnerable lost wages and at
least several innocent lives worse it
came out of nowhere
not as a response to inflation or
unrest so why then given all that we now
know is the policy still so popular in
India among those who personally paid
its costs like Xi Jinping's
consolidation of power in China
Modi successfully sold a story of
unfairness of targeting corruption and
criminals to ultimately gain political
support
soon after Modi's party won the 2017
elections of its 200 million person most
populous state in India thanks in part
to the popular belief that Dee
monetization was a collective sacrifice
necessary to make the rich pay their
fair share
anyone who protested the policy could
easily be labeled as a criminal trying
to hide black money rather than turning
the population against the government
Dee monetization enlisted it making
people feel they were personally doing
their part to help fight crime
Modi's party could have passed just as
effective but less disruptive laws
targeting black money and explained them
to gain support instead he knew the most
effective way to convey information is
by showing people firsthand D
monetization achieved its real goal of
driving political supports by making a
far away abstract concept tangible and
interactive likewise brilliant is a math
science and computer science website
that uses interactive teaching but for
good if you've ever wondered how Google
can search through literally billions of
results in less than a seconds or how to
win poker with probability or how
computers learn new things on their own
brilliant is for you one puzzle or game
or story at a time it takes you from the
very basics through to the most advanced
because you're watching this video I
know you'd like to learn new things so
why not check out brilliant and see
which of their over 60 topics you'd like
to learn next you can use the link in
the description to start learning
whatever interests you most for free and
the first 200 people will get 20% off
the annual premium subscription so you
can view all the daily challenges and
unlock dozens of problem-solving courses
thanks to brilliance and to you for
watching this video
you